[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 ya está conmigo en el estudio
rosa pérez más seguros a vamos a abrir
esta revista de prensa con la primera
colaboración que se ha hecho entre el
periódico 'el país' y france 24 en
español es que un equipo de periodistas
de ambos medios se desplazaron al
departamento de arauca particularmente a
la ciudad de saravena para conocer la
situación que hay allí con la guerrilla
ln y también las disidencias de las farc
no como dice el titular la ciudad donde
nos roban te matan buenos dias raúl es
exactamente por un lado queríamos pues
anunciar y celebrar esta colaboración
que la detallamos un poco pues estuvo
basada en que por parte del país juan
diego quesada y camilo rosso junto con a
nuestros compañeros
luís muñoz y el lyon el puchero se
desplazaron a los cuatro como decías al
departamento de arauca para documentar
la situación en esta área limítrofe con
venezuela donde como escribe quesada en
el país desde principios de año la
última guerrilla activa de colombia el
ejército de liberación nacional y las
disidencias de las farc en una batalla
cuerpo a cuerpo que tiene su foco
principal en saravena ciudad petrolera
situada en la frontera con venezuela y
fruto digamos de esta guerra entre
grupos armados esta ciudad saravena que
cuenta con una población de 43 mil
habitantes tiene uno de los mayores
índices de homicidio del mundo y
precisamente en este reportaje tanto en
la versión escrita como en la
audiovisual digamos aprendemos cómo la
población civil incluida pues los
líderes sociales amenazados como los ex
guerrilleros de la extinta guerrilla de
las farc reintegrados en la vida civil
pues viven en su cotidianidad en una de
las ciudades más peligrosas del planeta
también pues vemos como maniobra un
tercer actor armado el ejército de
colombia en toda esta disputa hay
digamos un diálogo que agita quesada en
el país en que el periodista pregunta
coronel cuántos asesinatos se han
resuelto de las decenas que habido desde
principios de año a lo que el coronel
responde tajantemente ninguno bueno
veamos un pequeño corte d reportaje pero
recuerden que lo pueden ver en su
integridad y también leer tanto en la
página web del país como en la de france
24 en español
los riesgos que se pueden presentar en
esta zona es la instalación de
artefactos explosivos sobre la vía
en colombia todavía hay guerra
en saravena en el oriental departamento
de arauca 78 personas han sido
asesinadas desde enero dos guerrillas el
ejército de liberación nacional y las
disidencias de las extintas farc luchan
por el control del territorio
estas son las instalaciones del
instituto colombiano agropecuario de
sarabela line y camina sobre las ruinas
en las que su padre trabajaba como
guardia de seguridad aquí el 19 enero
exactamente a las 10 35 de la noche un
carro bomba explotó en la parte del
frente del icap un atentado terrorista
hacia el edificio que se encontraba al
lado un reportaje que realmente vale la
pena de rosa y continuamos en colombia
en este caso hablamos de un texto
publicado en al yazira nos dejan sin
nada esto como la campaña contra la
deforestación en colombia ataca a los
agricultores y también ganaderos de
subsistencia exactamente es un reportaje
de christina noriega con imágenes
fotografías de andrés cardona que está
digamos realizado en san vicente del
cagüán aquí en colombia también y
básicamente cuenta pues a través de las
historias sobre todo sobre todo de dos
campesinas de anna y ver pino y gladys
galindo como la digamos la mala gestión
por decirlo de una forma suave de la
campaña artemis ésta afecta al pequeño
campesinado en lugar de a los grandes
capos digamos que explotan y que
promueven la deforestación del amazonas
recordemos esta campaña la operación
artemis fue lanzada en 2019 por iván
duque y fue la primera vez que una
operación contra la deforestación
implicaba a las fuerzas armadas del país
y lo que se denuncia en este artículo es
que se gastan miles de dólares en
detenciones de campesinos que residen en
áreas protegidas en muchos casos huyendo
de zonas de conflicto pero que la
deforestación no se reduce y en general
no para pues un poco sintetizar lo que
dice este artículo es que la operación
se ha centrado demasiado en los
escalones inferiores de los delitos
ambientales y que a veces se ha ido tras
los agricultores de subsistencia en
lugar de los verdaderos delincuentes que
talan grandes cantidades de árbol de
árboles o provocan grandes incendios no
también para abrir espacios para la
ganadería la minería o el cultivo de
plantas de coca rosa muy rápidamente no
quiero acabar revista de prensa sin
mostrar el texto del telespectador y
también la silla vacía para protesta las
propuestas de los dos candidatos
presidenciales roel fernández gustado
proyecto precisamente con lo que veíamos
la paz y la deforestación exacto real
porque también ambos temas están muy
relacionados no porque también uno
digamos de las cuestiones que ha hecho
que aumentara la deforestación es
digamos que tras los acuerdos de paz de
2016 el estado no ocupó muchas de las
zonas que abandonaron a las farc y ahí
pues a ser propicio que digamos grupos
armados de intereses económicos ocuparan
y explotaron estas zonas pero
rápidamente gustavo petro propone una
ley orgánica de ordenamiento territorial
detener la apropiación ilegal de predios
el narcotráfico y la minería en las
zonas de fronteras ugly agrícolas y como
decíamos desde un modelo sin estigmas de
criminalización de campesinos indígenas
y afrodescendientes mientras que rodolfo
hernández pretende reforzar las
autoridades militares y ambientales para
judicial izar los crímenes de minería y
deforestación en temas en temas de
seguridad en la cuestión de la ln ambos
quieren firmar un acuerdo de paz
petro propone un diálogo amplio y una
negociación mientras que rodolfo
pretende firmar un otrosí del acuerdo de
las farc rosa gracias nos vemos mañana
pasamos a saludar en nuestro segundo
invitado el día
[Música]